[Musique]
ibility looks to be May 20 feet or
so that any
of
[Musique]
est devenu le Nautilus a-t-il résisté
aux étreintes du
maestrom le capitaine Nemo est-il
toujours en vie poursuit-il sous l'océan
ses effrayantes représailles les flots
apporterontil un jour ce manuscrit qui
renferme toute l'histoire de sa vie
saurais-je enfin le nom de cet
homme presque tout ce qui est réalisé
aujourd'hui sous les mers grâce à la
technologie sous-marine a été imaginé
par
Jul alors pour moi ce livre est comme un
guide pour
l'avenir et quand le capitaine Nemo
parle des ville sous-marin du futur je
m'identifie beaucoup à lui parce que je
pense aussi au plus profond de moi qu'un
jour nous verrons des villes sous les
[Musique]
mers sur la côte ouest du Canada
dans la province de Colombie
Britannique il existe un homme qui ne
s'est jamais remis de ses lectures
d'enfance René Théophile
nuiten perpétue à sa manière les
aventures incroyables du commandant du
Nautilus le capitaine
Nemo des grciel plantés sur l'océan
Pacifique c'est ici à Vancouver à deux
pas des chantiers naval de la ville que
Phil nuen a pris le commandement d'une
entreprise h du
[Musique]
commun il y a plus de 40 ans le jeune
plongeur s'est fait une promesse il
voulait à tout prix déceler les énigmes
d'un monde sous-marin
inconnu l'homme a dédié toute sa vie et
surtout son métier à la découverte des
profondeurs
habales
estch plusieurs millénaires il est très
ancien très primitif et c'est pour cela
que la technique est comme une armure
qui nous autorise à aller où l'on ne
pourrait jamais aller avec notre
enveloppe corporelle
reingarde alors mon boulot c'est de
fabriquer des machines des engin pour
aller au fond de tous les
océans peu à peu et à quelques détails
près filen s'est construit un monde
identique à celui de son héros vernien
de 20 milieux sous les mers ce marin
reclu dans les abis est protégé par
l'épaisse cuirasse de son
[Musique]
Nautilus
ça c'est un mélangeur
d'oxygène riqu quand j'avais 12 ou 13
ans à l'intérieur il y a une petite
boîte en métal pour
respirer l'oxygène se trouve ici et pour
l'envoyer il suffit de faire cela
inspiration
expiration voilà tout se faisait à la
main et ça marchait bien avec cet
appareil je pouvais rester 40 minutes
sous l'eau enfin de 30 à 40
minutes je voulais construire quelque
chose de nouveau qui pouvait me
permettre de rester en bas c'est pour
cela que j'ai écrit ici même si j'étais
très jeune expérimental ce sigle SM en
fait ne veut rien dire machine d'urgence
sous-marine mais ça avait l'air
tellement bien tellement cool et si
scientifique nous allons de découverte
en
découverte petit à petit nous explique
sa manière de concevoir ses inventions
il nous livre même quelques secrets de
fabrication
ne vous inquiétez pas ça c'est du
polycarbonate et ça ne cassera pas c'est
très
solide je compte mettre une membrane ici
et cel va s'ouvrir et se fermer comme un
paraplu lque vous NZ vous faites cela
vers le bas jusquici ça s'ouvre puis
quand vous remontez cela se ferme
ferm
et prod je réféch
maintenier de constater si cette idée va
marcher ensuite je fabriquerai le
prochain modèle avec des matériaux plus
doux sans les vis et tout le reste avec
ça j'espère inventer une palme qui sera
très large au coup de pied vers le bas
et très étroite lorsque le pied
remonte les ateliers de fil nu ont des
air de
cafarnaum ici et là sont entassés des
centaines de souvenirs des restes
d'exploration ou encore quelques anciens
trophées
sous-marins c'est un véritable musée qui
s'ouvre où les pièces de haute
technologie côtoi la préhistoire de la
plongée
sous-marine voici l'Aquarius un
sous-marin pour TR personnes il a un
Huot immense le pilote s'assoie au fond
et commande l'engin avec des deux
caméras on l'utilise beaucoup pour des
travaux de surveillance pour le
département des pêches les ponts les
quais le passage des câbles sous-marins
et de
pipeline c'est un sous-marin idéal parce
qu'on peut transporter beaucoup
d'équipement à l'intérieur et il peut
rester sous l'eau de longue période tous
ces sous-marins ont au moins 3 jours
d'autonomie sous la mer alors en cas
d'urgence nous pouvons rester émergés
pendant 3 jours mais en général on reste
6 ou 8 heur sous l'eau
[Musique]
sousmarin s'appelle la loutre de mer on
l'a fabriqué ici en
1971 il a fait tellement de
plong toujours un problème avec la
petitesse des vous vouscarte alors votre
champ visuel rétréc à l'époque il
fallait être très très près pour voir
quelque
chose
des machines incroyables il y en a
partout il y en a dedans mais il y en a
aussi
dehors d'une pièce à l'autre on découvre
des bâtiscaf aux formes bizarre Phil
collectionne aussi de drôles de masques
de
plongée
c'est amusant parce que lorsque l'on
entre ici on voit des tas immenses de
vieilleries inutiles il y en a qui
disent que tout ce foutoir ressemble à
l'intérieur de ma tête parce que toutes
ces vieilles choses se mélangent avec
les
nouvelles je garde tout cela pour un
musée parce que je crois que pour
avancer dans la vie et connaître son
chemin il faut savoir d'ùon
[Musique]
vient
lorsqu'il est enfant Phil nen apprend à
nager dans les eaux profondes de
Colombie
Britannique à peine adolescent il
devient un chasseur sous-marin hors
[Musique]
paère plus tard le jeune canadien tient
une petite boutique de matériel de
plongée à Vancouvert il a 15 ans
[Musique]
alors
avec sa bande de copains il plonge dès
qu'ils le peuvent pour aller débusquer
des pieuvres géantes et autres monstres
marins qu'il revendent ensuite aux
aquariums de la ville de
[Musique]
Vancouver
n alors que de vieilles combinaisons de
caoutchou leur équipement est sommaire
mais le chasse souvent
miraculeuse le combat du capitaine Nemo
contre un calamar
géant c'est encore une histoire qui h
les pensées du jeune
fil
à l'époque le garçon a une spécialité
qui lui fait prendre des risques
importants il compte parmi les meilleur
lorsqu'il s'agit de se mesurer en apné
prolongé à plus de 20 m de
profondeur il est le meilleur jusqu'à ce
jour où en pleine compétition il reste
au fond complètement
[Musique]
inanimé
il y a deux choses que j'ai apprises du
fait d'être inconscient sous l'eau la
première c'est qu'on entend souvent que
votre vie défile devant vous alors que
vous êtes en train de vous
noyer et l'autre c'est que c'est
vraiment terrible de mourir noyé parce
qu'on étouffe on s'étrangle ces deux
choses dans mon cas étaient complètement
fausses j'ai retenu mon souffle le plus
longtemps possible lors de cette
compétition d'apné en eau
profonde j'ai pensé qu'en relâchant du
CO2 je pourrais rejoindre la
surface
mais dès que j'ai expiré j'ai inspiré de
l'eau mes
poumons la sensation c'était un
incroyable soulagement de l'eau froide
descendait dans ma poitrine avant je
brûlais à l'intérieur pour pouvoir
respirer et là je me suis senti très
lourd alors que j'essayais de remonter
le long du filin je me sentais si lourd
avec toute cette eau et si peu d'air je
palmais et Palma encore mais je me
voyais lentement glisser vers le
bas
ce jour-là si Phil n'avait pas laissé
l'eau de mer remplir ses poumons il
serait bel et bien
[Musique]
mort mais cette expérience traumatisante
n'a fait que renforcer son envie de
défier les
profondeurs et depuis il n'a cessé de
repousser les limites du corps humain
grâce à ses inventions il est devenu
l'un des pionniers en matière de plonger
dans des
dans les années 80 il est avec des
équipes de sentifi Canadiens le premier
à tent une descente sous les glaces de
[Musique]
l'Artique lorsque vous êtes assis au
bord du trou fait dans la glace et que
vous sentez l'eau au travers du nouvel
équipement que vous avez
fabriqué la plus grande peur c'est que
cela ne marche
pas l'au et d'essayer de respirer de
nager et de voir que cela marche comme
vous l'aviez prévu la sensation de
libération voir d'euphorie est
complètement
là ensuite seulement vous constatez que
l'eau est vraiment très froide qu'elle
s'insinue dans votre combinaison je
pouvais sentir comme une petite rivière
de chaleur sur mon
bras et bien que je suis au chaud et
bien je sais qu'au dehors c'est
glacial c'est un peu comme si vous étiez
dans un réfrigérateur et que le froid ne
vous avait pas encore atteint mais vous
pouvez sentir que le froid est bien
là mon plus beau souvenir de cette
époque c'est que c'était vraiment un
endroit étrange comme un autre monde
tout n'est que glace et
neige mais une fois dans l'eau
je ne me souviens que d'une chose ah je
suis si heureux que mon matériel
fonctionne si
[Musique]
bien affranchi des pesanteurs terrestres
le sombre capitaine Nemo cherchait la
vérité et la liberté dans les
profondeurs
fil nu lui puise son inspiration auprès
d'un peuple lié corsam à
l'océan il y a une trentaine d'années
est adopté par l'une des nombreuses
tribus indiennes de Colombie
[Musique]
Britannique les Indiens quala vivent ici
depuis des milliers d'années grâce au
richesses incroyabl des EAU du détroit
de Johnson
ils sont reconnus dans la région comme
les meilleurs sculpteurs de totem et de
masque
rituel issu d'une famille métisse de
l'intérieur des terres canadiennes pH
renoue ici avec une longue
tradition de temps à autre il aime
revenir sur l'île au cormorant une île
isolée au beau milieu d'un bras de mer
au nord-est de l'île de
Vancouver je suis venu ici quand j'étais
très jeune pour chercher des
informations sur le peuple
et à ma grande surprise bien des années
plus tard je suis revenu ici pour
plonger parce que c a des réserves très
limitées en eau
douce en fait l'eau est acheminée
jusqu'ici de l'île de Vancouver grâce un
pipeline alors avec l'un des très bons
plongeurs professionnels de cette île un
gars nommé bar Minton on avait
l'habitude de surveiller ce pipeline une
fois par an et je suis venu ici encore
et encore et c'était à chaque fois
l'occasion de de renouer des liens avec
les enfants que j'avais connu quand
j'étais
petit quand mon frère l'a rencontré il a
été très impressionné par fil c'est de
là je vous jure je vais pas vous
raconter tout ce qu'il faisait mais mais
bon ils étaient vraiment très bons amis
et c'est mon frère qui a pensé à
l'adopter il m'a téléphoné et on a
organisé une grande cérémonie dans la
maison des anciens
je suis très fier très heureux de
l'avoir comme
sœur lors de cette
adoption voilà ce que la famille
dit nous prenons la responsabilité de
cet homme cet homme nous appartient
désormais et nous prenons donc toutes
les responsabilités pour ses actes sa
conduite et
cetera et ça c'est un engagement très
important pour cette famille ils ne font
cela que s'ils pensent que c'est
bénéfique pour leur communauté
c'est donc un rituel fondamental dans
cette
culture le capitaine Nemo prenait fê
Cuse pour un jeune Indien pêcheur de
perle qu à lui se bat pour que les
anciennes uvres d'art confisqué aux
Indiens puis dispersé de par le monde
reviennent sur l'Î
cor
[Musique]
la culture de ce peuple est à la fois si
simple et si complexe
pour moi c'est une véritable analogie
avec toutes les missions sous-marines
que nous faisons de par le monde souvent
quand je suis sous l'eau je pense aux
cérémonies traditionnelles des potes
lâche leur chant les danses indiennes
c'est étonnant comme tout cela prend du
sens dans un endroit comme
[Musique]
celui-ci
après ce voyage initiatique et une
plongée au cœur de l'imaginaire de notre
Nemo des temps modernes nous rentrons à
[Musique]
Vancouver
c'est ici dans ces ateliers que Phil met
au point la plupart des engins consacrés
aux travaux
[Musique]
sous-marins son équipage d'ingénieur est
composé d'anciens plongeurs ou
scafandriers professionnel
aujourd'hui pH est devenu un businessman
redoutable Jeff son bras droit en sait
quelque chose le jeune pilote de
sous-marin est l'un des rares à partager
les prouess techniques de ses machines
digne d'un roman de
science-fiction
quand nous présente un dessin en général
ma réaction c'est la
peur je dis pas ça pour faire du mauvais
esprit parce que je sais qu'il a pensé
tel ou tel véhicule dans sa
tête il l' mis sur le
papier il va nous donner la mission de
construire je ne nous lâchera pas d'un
pouce avant que sa nouvelle invention ne
devienne
réalité on nous a toujours appris que
l'une des choses qui distinguait l'homme
de l'animal est cette opposition entre
notre pouce et les autres
doigts mais c'est pas vrai car si
c'était vrai et que seul ce mouvement
était nécessaire alors Lesar les C
dirigerai le
monde en fait ce qui est utile ça n'est
pas uniquement ce mouvement là mais
aussi et surtout
celui-là pour fil c'est donc
l'observation et surtout l'instinct qui
[Musique]
prime regardez quand je ser ici je peux
ressentir la texture et la forme
exactement comme si je le faisais avec
mes propres doigts
tout ce que je fais avec ma main est
relié ici avec de petites es
[Musique]
d'acier après après avoir frôé la mort
sous l'eau après avoir vu disparaître
ses compagnons de plongé lors d'accident
de décompression l'ancien scapfandrier
n'a de cesse d'inventer d'étranges
véhicules
[Musique]
subaquatiques pour aller toujours plus
loin et toujours plus profond sans cette
angoisse de l'accident Phil invente des
combinaisons
futuristes des robots téléguidés de
véritables va des mers autant d'outils
pour la recherche scientifique les
travaux sous-marins ou encore la
découverte de cet univers passionnant
que sont les entrailles de
[Musique]
l'océan lorsque je relis le temps passé
à bord du Nautilus tous ces événements
heureux ou malheureux depuis ma
disparition de l'Abraham
Lincoln le sous-marin en chasse les
Papou et les sauvages le cimetière de
corille le tunnel de suè les STERIN la
baie de Vigot l'Atlantis le banc de
glace le Pôle Sud l'emprisonnement dans
les glaces la bataille contre la pieuvre
les tempêtes du golfstam et l'horrible
scène de ce bateau coulé avec son
équipage tous ces événements passent au
travers de ma tête comme le décor d'un
théâtre et le capitaine Nemo apparaît
disproportionné il n'était plus comme
moi un homme mais un génie de la
merè
[Musique]
Nemo parcourait sans relâche le monde
invisible des mers l'insatiable fil
compte lui aussi grâce à ses inventions
géniales laisser son nom gravé dans les
pages de l'histoire des
abis
ce matin fil et son équipage de plongeur
quit Vancouver en direction des
montagnes du
Nord cette fois l'expédition sera courte
avec le mauvais temps ils n'auront que
de jours pour tester les capacité d'un
nouveau sous-marin de poche le Deep
worker inér dans cet endroit c'est de
voir que les abis de l'océan Pacifique
sont si proches de
Vancouver à l'instant précis il y a 300
m de profondeur alors que nous ne sommes
pas très éloignés du rivage toutes ces
îles qui sortent de la mer comme des
montagnes j'ai vécu ici toute ma vie et
je ne me lasse pas de regarder tout cela
c'est fascinant de trouver des endroits
où la civilisation et le monde sauvage
sont si rapprochés c'est
magnifique le capitaine no command le
Nautilus Phil lui se contente d'un
minuscule sous-marin qui l'a surnommé le
travailleur des profondeurs c'est le
dernier né de sa flotte sous-marine et
c'est encore une fois une avancée
incroyable pour le monde de la plongée
et la découverte des habyss
[Musique]
océaniques
l'Aquarius d'un côté et le Deep worker
de l'autre unique en son
genre Phil orchestre la manœuvvere tel
un pilote de chasse avant des exercices
en
vol ces opérations en mer sont très
délicates
au command du deeper une fois sous l'eau
c'est qui va mener la
danse sera quelques mètres de lui quand
il commencera ses
manvres que quelis ça Devi peu effant
mais il suffit de mettre peu d' dans
sonit pourend compte qu'une fois en il n
a rien qui pour faire du
malrobe vous pouvez constater qu'il n'y
a pas beaucoup de place làdans le plus
étonnant c'est qu'une fois fermé une
fois que vous êtes assis depuis 15 à 20
minutes alors vous vous sentez rétrécir
alors que l'espace lui s'agrandit ouais
c'est vraiment la chose la plus
étonnante je ne peux pas expliquer
comment et pourquoi cela se produit mais
d'un seul coup tout devient assez grand
[Musique]
là-dedans nous arrivons de seelt c'est
un passageer 3 un genre de fiorde et
maintenant nous arrivons dans cette
petite
baie où il y a la flèche rouge se trouve
une épave qu'on appelle la chaudière
c'est une épave superbe nous allons
mouiller par ici parce que cette épave
représente une plateforme idéale pour
stationner nos sous-marins avant les
tests et le fait de nous trouver juste
audessus des fonds nous évite de
soulever la vase du coup nous pouvons
obtenir des photographies parfaites de
ces
[Musique]
essais
le gros va essayer de
passer
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose d'incroyablement
gratifiant lorsque l'eau vous recouvre
la tête vous fermez les yeux vous
regarder autour et là vous vous dites ça
marche je suis vivant à ce moment-là
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir construit
de vos mains un engin qui vous permet
d'aller sous l'eau c'est un test
immédiat sans appel il n'y a pas de
théorie pour cela une fois que vous êtes
en dessous soit ça marche soit ça ne
marche
[Musique]
pas installés dans l'Aquarius Phil et
Jeff partent à la rencontre du Deep
[Musique]
worker ils commencent leur land descente
à la recherche d'un bâtiment militaire
datant de la Seconde Guerre
[Musique]
mondiale l'quarius négatif je n'ai pas
encore les pas en vu pour l'instant
terminé
ça y est on a lespaves droit devant
[Musique]
nous le navire est couché sur son flanc
on distingue à peine ses canons et sa
[Musique]
cheminée quand soudain deux petites
lueurs apparaissent derrière la coque
rouillée
[Musique]
HP2
lp8 un s-marin qui vole c'est si
beau
ok je te reçois je reste en
alerte tu peux commencer les essa de
[Musique]
manipulation
regardez quand je suis allongé dans ce
sous-marin je n'ai rien sur le visage
rien dans la bouche c'est comme si
j'étais à la
surface
alors dans ces moments le rêve d'une
ville subaquatique c'estàdire un lieuù
on pourrait vivre et travailler ce rêve
devient réel C relève bien s de la
sciencefiction mais ici au fond de la
mer dans ce sous-marin avec le de à
l'extérieur qui stationne sur le pont
d'une épave soudainement il semble plus
que cela soit un si grand rêve une si
grande étape à franchir peut-être que
cela arrivera bien plôt qu'on le
pense
[Musique]
vivre sous la mer comme sur terre voici
le grand rêve de
Phil les castes font d'ailleurs souvent
appel à lui pour dessiner et concevoir
les costumes ou les machines infernales
de leurs aventures
sous-marineses rêves de gamin prennent à
leur vie comme dans le film abis une
super production de James
[Musique]
Cameron je me demande souvent qu'aurait
pensé le capitaine Nemo de tout cela
mais plus important encore qu'aurait
donné Jul Verne pour être dans la
position où je me trouve
actuellement être là au fond de l'océan
et regarder à travers cette grande bulle
c'est tout de même un décor qu'il a vu
uniquement dans son imagination alors
voir ces choses qu'il a vu dans son
esprit les voir pour de vrai j'imagine
qu'il aurait donné n'importe quoi pour
voir
ça
[Musique]
avec toutes ces inventions Phil a fait
fortune sur le marché des engins
sous-marins le petit deepwer intéresse
de plus en plus certains milliardaair en
mal de sensation qui veulent faire de la
plongée sous-marine en non profonde un
nouveau
loisir
en attendant que des villes tout
entières surgissent dans l'obscurité des
océans il est grand temps que Ph rentre
à Vancouver afin de poursuivre ses
recherches
[Musique]
interminables
dans les bassins du centre d'essai
maritime de la ville il tente de mettre
au point depuis près de 10 ans un
scapfandre
[Musique]
révolutionnaire une combinaison capable
de transporter un homme à plus de 300 m
sous la mer dans un confort presque
[Musique]
parfait
après la conquête de l'espace la guerre
des
profondeurs Phil travaille sans relâche
parce qu'il sait qu'un jour les fonds
marins deviendront un enjeu économique
colossal et ce jour-là il compte bien
être en première
[Musique]
ligne
il y a toujours des situations où on a
l'impression que le mauvais sortarne sur
vous mais si vous arrivez ne serait
qu'une seule fois à faire marcher votre
invention alors le système fonctionnera
ce matin on a v une n parfaite alors
c'était bon avec une seule n réussie on
sait que cela pourra se faire une
nouvelle
fois
[Applaudissements]
on dit que c'est un peu comme des
canards qui vous pinent les doigts c'est
très difficile de faire mal à quelqu'un
de cette manière mais petit à petit il
finissent par vous manger tout
entier le scafandre ultra mododerne
n'est pas encore sur le marché et déjà
il attire toutes les attention et
notamment celle des
[Applaudissements]
militaires
cette nouvelle combinaison va tout
changer pour les plongeurs militaires
ils ne seront plus esclaves de la
pression de la décompression ils
pourront rester sous l'eau pendant de
très longues périodes par exemple ils
pourront quitter un sous-marin nucléaire
se rendre discrètement jusqu'au rivage
avec un petit moyen de
propulsion il y a quelques années de
cela nous avons rencontré pas mal de
mercenaires des soldats de fortune je
leur ai demandé pourquoi est-ce que vous
portez autant d'intérêt à posséder cette
combinaison pour une ou de personne et
pourquoi pas pour tout un
régiment il m'ont répondu il suffit
d'avoir une ou deux personnes bien
équipées au cœur de la bataille et c'est
[Musique]
gagné en attendant de futur conflit
sous-marin la nuit tombe sur
Vancouver et lorsque les affaires se
font trop pressantes pH a parfois besoin
de retrouver son univers
imaginaire quand il n'est pas sous la
mer il s'échappe dans un petit atelier
secret situé juste à côté de sa
maison lorsqu'il a été adopté par les
Indiens de l'île au cormorant les chefs
du clan lui ont donné un droit un genre
d'héritage dont il doit prendre le plus
grand
soin c'est à lui que revient la charge
de sculpter des totems des masques ou
encore des bijoux pour les cérémonies
traditionnelles ils lui ont même donné
le nom d'un grand poisson en guise de
totem le Red Snapper
[Musique]
dans la tradition des
Indiens on pense que c'est le roi du
monde
sous-marin la raison c'est que la
couleur de ce poisson sous l'eau est
comme le
cuivre et tout le poisson sera recouvert
de cuivre de cette couleur
là chez lesult
la personne qui possède le plus de
cuivre comme par exemple ces plaques
rituels est considéré comme l'homme le
plus riche du
village alors par
extrapolation ils disent qu'un poisson
recouvert de cuivre doit être le roi du
monde
sous-marin et figurez-vous que mon nom
traditionnel est clxom ce qui signifie
Red
[Musique]
Snapper
so how
look
primitif cette discipline très rigide
qui remonte à des milliers d'années est
très différente des technologies
sous-marines
dernierscit mais pour moi ces deux
choses se rejoignent complètement parce
que lorsque je sculpte je me surprends à
rêver à des créatures
sous-marines je dessine alors un poisson
un aigle marin et je pense à eux sous
l'eau et puis parfois lorsque je suis
dans mes sous-marins et que j'attends
par exemple qu'on veut bien bouger la
grue avant de descendre et bien je pense
à la danse je pense à mes masques ou je
ne sais quoi encore il y a longtemps les
Indiens croyaient qu'un monde
subaquatique existait un monde semblable
à notre monde en surface il pensait
aussi que chaque animal et chaque être
humain possédait un double sous l'eau il
croyait aussi que les fonds des mers
étaient la demeure des noyés et par
exemple lorsque l'un deeux se noyait il
pensait qu'il allait vivre une nouvelle
vie sous
l'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de temps en temps c'est vrai qu'il est
si pris par les choses qu'il fait il ne
se rend plus compte de ce qui se passe
autour de
lui mais c'est peut-être là tout le
secret de sa
réussite Mo jeup ch du quotidien pour le
laisser non seulement
rêver mais aussi
explorer et faire aboutir ses
projets on peut dire effectivement qu'
qu'il ne vit pas tout à fait sur notre
[Musique]
planète
à défaut de vivre sous l'eau Phil et
Mary sa femme s'envolent vers une petite
île boisée située à 20 minutes de leur
maison de
[Musique]
vcouvert c'est leur refuge familial loin
des bruits de l'atelier et des grands
projets
[Musique]
sous-marins à l'image de Nemo le
commandant du
Nautilus notre inventeur s'est trouvé
une île mystérieuse un endroit retiré du
[Musique]
monde quand je relis ce livre et toutes
les aventures étranges du
Nautilus du personnage conseil du
Canadien N et bien sûr de Nemo et de son
équipage je ne peux m'empêcher de penser
à ma propre aventure autour du monde à
toutes ces plongées un peu partout de
l'Arctique canadien sous les glaces
jusqu'au golf du Mexique de la côte
pacifique d'Amérique du Nord au côtes de
l'Atlantique de la France et de la
Méditerranée des plongé au FIDI à Tahiti
en Australie les gens me demandent
souvent mais quel est votre endroit
préféré bien là je dois admettre que mon
lieu préféré a toujours été ici en
Colombie Britannique sur cette île de
Galliano qui est pour moi le plus bel
endroit du
[Musique]
monde
tout au long de ce voyage dans
l'imaginaire de Phil nuitain en relisant
avec lui toutes ses aventures
sous-marines en plongeant à bord de ses
engins du
futur nous avons acquis une
certitude l'esprit du capitaine Nemo est
bel et bien vivant il navigue quelque
part au large des côtes de Colombie
Britannique
[Musique]